tell me about thirsty and song on sand
bursting into song I mean that's we were
lucky in that Jessica Mauboy is this
incredible singer and loved singing like
we'll just be walking around singing all
of the time so everybody feels
comfortable just banging out tunes all
the time that made me sound really heavy
I'm not sure if I can get away with
saying banging out tunes anymore I
suddenly felt very old when I said that
phrase but it was it was it was quite
joyous and what was it about the script
that appeal to I felt like I didn't know
the world it felt very new to me and I
felt ignorant about it which is always
tantalizing and the music is just
incredible I wants to ask you about
craft in the comedy how it come heard in
the UK the states are now Australia as
long as the people that are at the top
of the tree have the same kind of
sensibilities it doesn't really matter
and I find that the differences are
probably far less and you would imagine
in terms of whether it's Graham Linehan
or Judd Apatow or Wayne this they find
the same things funny so as long as I
can make some of those things happen
then it's a very similar experience
you